- - Je surfe la vague
etet je suis gay.
- - Aujourd'hui, je peux dire
quque je suis un survivant.
- - J'étais trop fière pour
gagarder ça en dedans de moi.
- - C'est un parcours
tetellement personnel!
- - En compagnie de Debbie
LyLynch-White...
- - J'ai envie de mettre
enen lumière ce moment-là
ouoù ils se sont choisis.
V Vous avez peut-être vu, dans
leles derniers mois, cette série
dodocumentaire "Histoires
dede Coming Out".
C'C'est l'une des nombreuses
réréalisations de l'artiste Debe
LyLynch-White, dans la lutte
cocontre l'homophobie et
lala transphobie.
UnUne artiste multidisciplinair.
D'D'ailleurs, elle vient tout
jujuste de recevoir le prix
LaLaurent-McCutcheon pour
sosouligner sa contribution
àà la cause.
IlIl a été un militant durant
plplusieurs décennies pour les
drdroits d'LGBTQ+.
ElElle a excepté de nous parler
dedepuis le lieu où elle va
rerecevoir ce prix.
D'D'abord bonsoir et qu'est-ce e
çaça représente pour vous?
- - C'est énorme, pour moi, je
vovous avoue... je dois avouer e
çaça m'émeut davantage qu'un
prprix... dans ce que j'ai envie
dede mettre en lumière puis cete
rereconnaissance me touche
vrvraiment beaucoup.
C'C'est un grand honneur, c'esta
prpremière fois que je reçois un
prprix de ce genre.
OuOui, je suis très fébrile.
- - Évidemment, "coming out",
sosorte de placard en français,
popour vous ça s'est bien passé,
mamais est-ce que c'est importat
ququand on est une personnalité
pupublique comme vous de le dir,
dede le faire pour aider les
auautres et permettre de lutter
cocontre l'homophobie?
- - Je pense que oui.
EnEn fait, je pense que plus on
sesera à faire notre "coming ou,
plplus on engagera le dialogue,n
vava faire tomber des barrièrest
l'l'ignorance de certaines
pepersonnes.
PoPour moi, c'est quelque chose
d'd'important, je veux défendre.
JeJe comprends le parcours
pepersonnel de chaque personne,
chchacun le vit à sa façon.
PoPour moi je ne pouvais pas ne
papas le faire, c'est ce que je
susuis à tous les jours.
- - C'est votre identité, c'esta
nonormalité.
- - Oui, je suis la même persone
àà la télé que dans la vie, je
veveux cette cohérence et je vex
ututiliser ma tribune pour les
gegens qui en ont pas.
- - Est-ce que ça a été ça
l'l'impact de la série
dodocumentaire, d'être en
cocommunion avec les gens qui ot
bebesoin d'être guidés dans cete
dédémarche.
VoVous rêvez du jour où ce ne sa
plplus nécessaire, où tout le
momonde sera accepté.
- - Absolument, c'est un peu
l'l'objectif que j'avais avec la
sésérie au départ.
ApAprès, j'ai nuancé un peu la
réréflexion, il y a des gens por
ququi le "coming out" est un
prprocessus important pour eux.
LeLe bus NE parle ne plus en
fafaire, mais c'est pour que les
gegens ne perdent plus leur empi
popour ça.
EtEt tous ceux qui arrivent, que
leles gens ne vivent plus
d'd'homophobie ou de transport .
C'C'est ce que je voulais mettre
enen lumière.
- - Vous, avez-vous vécu de
l'l'homophobie à travers les
anannées?
EsEst-ce que ça a motivé votre
enengagement?
- - Un petit peu, je dois avouer
quque j'ai été très chanceuse ds
lele sens que je sais qu'il y a
dedes personnalités publiques en
onont vécu plus que moi.
JeJe suis témoin d'homophobie,
j'j'ai des gens, toutes sortes e
gegens qui m'ont écrit des
cecentaines de messages pour me
raraconter leur histoire.
OuOui, au Québec on dit qu'on et
bibien et qu'on est chanceux, ms
ilil y a encore du chemin à fai.
IlIl faut encore parler.
CeCe que je trouve beau, et c'et
momon ami Simon Boulerice qui ma
didit ça dans la série, je troue
quque maintenant on pointe plusu
dodoigt l'homophobe que
l'l'homosexuel.
CÇa, pour moi, ça m'a rempli
d'd'espoir pour la suite des
chchoses.
- - Qu'est-ce qu'on doit dire ax
hohomophobes?
QuQuestion de faire pour qu'ils
chchangent leur vision?
- - Bien, de discuter avec les
gegens, de discuter... on ne
coconnaît jamais les histoires s
gegens que l'on rencontre et
d'd'être curieux de l'autre ça
dédéveloppe notre empathie, ça
fafait tomber l'ignorance a fait
totomber les barrières.
OnOn se rend compte qu'on est ts
huhumain et que l'amour, c'est
l'l'amour.
CÇa se résume à ça en bout de
liligne.
OnOn veut tous être aimé, on vet
auaussi aimer.
JeJe pense que c'est de parler,
c'c'est de ne pas avoir peur.
- - Il y a un sondage qui a été
fafait par le Refondation
d'd'émergence, la firme Léger, i
rérévèle que 65 % des personnes
d'd'LGBTQ+ ont reçu de
l'l'harcèlement psychologique au
trtravail, 40 % des Québécois ot
dédémissionné, et d'autres ont
pepensé le faire.
SaSans parler des cas de suicide
asassocié à cette difficulté
d'd'assumer, de comprendre, cete
sasalade s'expliquait, mais on e
pepeut pas prendre ça à l'légèr.
CÇa a des conséquences
imimportantes sur la vie des ge.
- - Absolument.
EnEncore dernièrement au Québec,
unun jeune de 10 ans qui s'est
mamalheureusement enlevé la vie
paparce qu'il était une personne
trtrans, il vivait de l'trans Ty
avavec ça.
PePeut-être qu'il manquait de
reressources pour traverser ça,
ououi, il y a des choses terribs
ququi se passent et il ne faut
plplus que ça se passe.
- - Il faut parler aux parents .
IlIl y a des rejets qui se font,
ququi sont subies par les
pepersonnes qui sortent du placd
auauprès des familles.
- - Oui, absolument.
EnEncore une fois ça repose, je
pepense, sur beaucoup de préjug,
dedes ignorance qui en est 1022
nonon plus de place.
OnOn doit continueuer à les faie
totomber.
- - Debbie Lynch-White, je vousi
apappris qu'une partie de la
réréforme du Code civil a été
adadoptée hier, lors de la paus,
popourriez-vous me rejouer votre
réréaction quand je vous ai apps
nonotamment que désormais on
ututilisera le mots parents plut
quque père et mère sur les
reregistres des entités civilest
onon aura plus à caser homme ou
fefemme, on pourra indiquer son
ididentité de genre, dites-moi e
quque vous avez dit durant la
papause.
- - Je ne savais pas.
JeJe n'étais pas au courant et
c'c'est absolument génial.
CÇa me remplit de joie.
- - Alors, qu'est-ce que ça veut
didire concrètement par exemple
auaux couples qui ont des enfan,
etet qui vont pouvoir assumer
cocomplètement leur identité?
- - C'est sûr que ça doit créere
lala confusion, ça doit créer ds
ininconforts.
JeJe ne suis pas parents, mais e
coconnais des gens, justement, e
fefemmes, elles ne veulent pas
s's'identifier comme un homme,
cocomme un père, il y avait un
esespèce de flou.
EtEt je suis très heureuse qu'on
esest réglé, et que ça continue
dadans ce sens.
DaDans la bureaucratie, oui, das
totoute la paperasse, il y a des
chchoses, un petit ménage à fai.
- - Très bien.
QuQu'est-ce qu'on vous souhaite
popour l'avenir?
VoVous allez continuer cette
enengagement contre l'homophobi?
- - Oui, absolument.
JeJe vais continuer parce que je
n'n'ai pas d'autre choix à mon
avavis.
C'C'est tout naturel.
OuOui, je vais continuer avec
jojoie.
JeJe ne sais pas ce sera sous
ququelle forme.
JuJuste d'être visible avec ma
fefemme dans les médias, ça fait
unun impact sur les personnes qi
m'm'écrivent.
CÇa, pour moi c'est mon plus grs
enengagement au quotidien.
- - Les compagnies et banque meà
l'l'affiche, ça contribue à rene
unun message. Je rappelle que vs
alallez recevoir...
- - Oui vraiment.
NoNon vraiment, j'allais dire oi
etet je suis toujours très excié
ququand on voit, très sérieuse
ququand on voit un couple de Gu,
cocoupe de lesbiennes dans une
pupublicité.
CÇa fait la différence.
PaParce que, comme personne dans
lala communauté LGBTQ+, on a
bebesoin de se représenter.
QuQuand on voit ça, pour une
pepersonne lesbienne, ça nous ft
ququelque chose dans le ventre.
CeCe sentiment-là, on n'en a pls
bebesoin, on a tout besoin de
s's'identifier.
JeJe vais vous dire que ça j'ade
çaça.
AÀ chaque fois j'envoie à la
tétélé, ça me fait du bien.
- - Merci beaucoup Debbie Lynch-
WhWhite, dans quelques instantsn
vava vous remettre un prix conte
l'l'homophobie et les droits des
pepersonnes d'LGBTQ+.
BoBonne soirée à vous et célébre